Homeopathy,
maybe the most controversial but also
the most popular alternative medicine
while some argue against it, others swear
by it's great power and effectiveness.
How does homeopathy work?
How did it become what it is today and
what can modern medicine none from it.
The first principle of homeopathy
is a blank cures like remedies using
ingredients that caused the symptoms
you want to kill in practice.
That means that remedies
against fever could for example,
be made from Bella Donna,
which also causes fever.
A mixture based from be venom is used
to treat ECI swellings and so on.
The second principle is a special method
of preparation called potentialization.
The idea is that diluting and agitating
the ingredients activates their curative
powers and enhances their effect.
To do this,
the ingredient is dissolved
in alcohol or distilled water.
Homeopaths take one part of the solution
and mix it with nine parts of water,
diluting it down to one 10th of its
original concentration and shaking it.
What you have now is a one x potency,
one part ingredient and my part solvent
named after the Roman numeral x for 10
now this process is repeated.
Take one part,
mix it with nine parts of pure water and
shake it vigorously. Now you have two x,
you do this again and again until you
reach the desired grade of potency.
The finished remedy is then taken orally
or sometimes it's applied as little
sugar packet that are sold as
globally. A 20 x potency, for example,
is like dissolving one aspirin pill in
the water volume of the whole Atlantic,
but many are much more extreme
length. 30 see, for example,
c means that the mixture has one
part ingredient and 99 parts water,
so the commonly sold 30 see mixture means
that one part ingredient and 1 million
billion, billion, billion, billion,
billion, billion parts of water.
If we wanted a globally pill with a single
atom of the original ingredient than
our pill would be the diameter of the
distance between the earth and the sun.
150 million kilometers uphill,
so massive that it would collapse
into a black hole under its own mass.
Because of this potentaty [inaudible]
is one of the biggest criticisms of
homeopathy. The extreme
dilution is supposed to make
the ingredients more potent,
but on a physical level,
this doesn't really make sense.
Most homeopathic remedies aren't diluted
so much that not a single atom of the
active ingredient is left in the,
the explanation of why the mixture still
work is that shaking them extra after
every dilution leaves behind a spirit,
like essence of the ingredient.
Basically. The idea is that ought
to remembers what was put into it.
But if this were true,
then every substance that ever a drop
of water would leave the essence behind
and lead to unpredictable effects
when it was accidentally ingested.
Think of all the stuff that
lives in floats in the oceans.
Every sip of water would be a
supercharged homeopathic cocktail.
So how did homeopathy become the
most successful alternative medicine?
And the 18th century medicine
was very different from today.
Treatments like bloodletting left the
patient worse off than before. So,
and physicians are unwell.
Honamin wanted a noninvasive,
natural way of healing and
developed homeopathy. And in fact,
homeopathic hospitals were soon successful
because doing no harm beats doing
harm. Honoman imposed very strict
rules on his patients. First,
you had to avoid coffee, tea,
alcohol, spicy foods, sweet fruit,
no old cheese, no onions, no meat,
no clothes made from sheep's wool,
but also know sedentary work, low sitting
inside in stuffy air, no warm rooms,
no riding horses, no
napping, no playing games,
no masturbation and of course no reading,
pornographic tax and many more.
Then and only then would his remedies
work according to the inventor of
homeopathy.
Of course,
all of these instructions are
ignored and not talked about today.
Medicine has changed a
lot in the last 150 years.
Never before in human history have we
enjoyed a comparable level of health.
Never have we lived as long and this
is largely due to the new tools we've
developed.
Modern Diagnostics,
double blinded studies and scientific
evaluation to check and to prove which
stuff works. Thanks to these tools.
After countless studies and reviews,
we know beyond a shadow of a doubt that
homeopathy does not have any effect
beyond placebo. But even
so, who cares why it works?
If it helps people,
maybe you tried it and felt better or
you know someone that got over a horrible
disease while using homeopathic remedies
and there are plenty of reports of it
working for children and animals.
What do we make of these experiences?
The placebo effect is very
real and not imaginary.
No matter how smart you are,
you're not immune to it.
If people believe that something
will help them feel better,
their trust alone has the desired effect
and it's been proven that the placebo
effect can be transferred.
Children and animals rely on their parents
or keep us and are in tune to their
emotions. If a parent has a lot of
trust and a treatment and it eases up,
this can help a child relax
and help relieve symptoms.
This could also be observed with animals
who react strongly to the body language
cues of the people caring for them,
but the most powerful tool
of homeopathy is time.
Our bodies are survival
machines. Infections pass on
their own after a few days,
but if you take some remedy when you
already feel sick and then start getting
better, it feels like it
did indeed kill you. Well,
actually it would have happened anyway.
The homeopathy industry likes to play
the gentle alternative to big Pharma,
but the homeopathic
industry is big Pharma.
Billions of dollars are made
with extreme profit margins.
The homeopathy industry has its own lobby
organizations and fights its enemies
as hard as it can. A lot of
money is on the line. Globally.
The market is expected to reach over 17
billion by 2020 for some critics even
argue that the homeopathic industry is
bad for public health because it creates
distrust and proven medicine.
The belief in homeopathy correlates
with skepticism about vaccinations.
This can discourage people to seek the
help they need when their lives or the
lives of their children are on the line,
but there is actually a key to the
success of homeopathy that we could and
should copy.
The first consultation with a homeopath
can take hours and is very personal.
For a patient who's already been on
a pilgrimage from doctors, a doctor,
this level of attention and empathy
can make a huge difference to their
wellbeing even if the conversation
was not the point of the therapy.
Modern medicine is efficient.
It saves millions of lives each year,
but it's also a strictly
organized system type. Budgets,
forced doctors and nurses to
deal with lots of patients.
Consultations need to be time efficient.
Diagnoses made quickly,
treatments fast, which can leave
patients feeling invisible,
scared and left behind.
This is what modern medicine
can learn from homeopathy.
It meets a human need that
has been left unfulfilled.
We need to make time for the individual
again, see people, not numbers,
but as important as empathy is. It's
not a substitute for actual treatment.
Faith can move mountains, but
sugar, water can't cure cancer.
After a short break of a few years
could cause. Alta is back in Jevon.
Thanks to the support of funk.
We have relaunched the German channel
and are beginning to upload a video every
one to two weeks.
Besides redoing our favorite videos,
there'll be a number of videos that
will not exist in English for a while.
Check out the channel here. Tell us what
you think, and subscribe and wash a few.
If the channel goes well,
the German videos might become
a regular thing for years,
and we might even do more languages.